Now we'd like you to write this flip book animation style in code. We've given
you a list of image assets to use for "Evil Devices". What you need to do is load
all of these image assets and place them in the frame array. After your images
are loaded, you should go through and fill out the rest of the animation
function here, which will actually draw the flip book animation images to the
screen as we described before. Make sure that when your animation is finished
you loop back to the beginning. Now before this you need to have some logic
that checks for whether or not the images are loaded, and once all of the frames
have been loaded, actually does a call to setInterval. Now setInterval takes
as input a pointer to a function you'd like to call as well as a millisecond
count on how often you want it to be called. So, for instance, if I made a
function and wanted it to be called once every 30 milliseconds, those would be
parameters that I pass into it. Make sure that your setInterval call, actually
calls the animate function, once every 30 milliseconds.